[Applause]
well greetings and salutations
uh from florida and from austin texas
i'm so pleased today to bring
christopher cole
on to down the middle for the first time
uh
you're the chief investment officer
founder of artemis capital
if there was ever a bond king in the
investment
environment in the investment community
i would call you the volatility king
uh because you know more about it than
i'll ever anybody
will probably ever know um and when
when you think of the word volatility
and the idea
of volatility and movement the last
thing that comes to mind
is 10 hours a day
of meditation 10 hours a day
for days on end outside of dallas texas
so um i want to get into your brain a
little bit
tell me why why you decided
to to do that and i was i i was tickled
that you said
you don't have to go to bali uh to
meditate
but walk us through that experience
yeah first of all thank you for that
kind introduction i would i would never
call myself
the volatility team there's so many
intelligent people
uh in this space uh so hopefully
and humbly hopefully i've provided some
aspect of discussion
to the discussion some benefit to the
discussion um but i
but i'm i'm really uh honored that uh
you think highly to that effect um but
to
to go and talk a little bit about the
meditation um
yeah i know we talked about like what's
a personal anecdote one of the things i
think people don't really
know about me is that i've been
meditating uh really consistently for
the past
five years um but back in uh
back in 2019 it was actually before the
pandemic
i went ahead and did something i had
never done before which was to do a
10-day meditation retreat
and so i the way i think about
meditation
uh you know an athlete needs to train
the body
lebron james is out there training his
body making sure his body's recovered
i think we're mental athletes ui and
anyone else in markets are former mental
athletes
um and that part of that training
comes down to being able to to
understand the signal from the noise and
focus and so i began this practice of
meditation
uh which i found incredibly helpful for
that
the idea of doing a 10-day meditation
retreat was was a pretty crazy
experience
uh meditating 10 hours a day
no talking you're in one spot
no reading no writing no phone no
internet
uh you all your meals are before noon
you wake up at four in the morning and
you do 10 hours of meditation and pure
silence over the course of the day for
10 straight days
uh it was one of the most challenging
things i've ever done in my life and you
really
forget how frenetic the mind is
and how difficult it is to quiet that
mind
um and i learned something very
interesting about
what life and about meditation that kind
of relates to markets in this way
you're trying to quiet your mind and
you're constantly thinking about
all of these uncomfortable uh
sensations or sensations you enjoy
if you're sitting for 10 hours a day it
hurts
it physically hurts
your back hurts your knees
your legs are falling asleep i'm hurting
listening to it yes
yeah it's it's extremely difficult um
so as part of that you have to just
recognize that the pain exists
and not assign any judgment to it
likewise if you feel something good
sometimes there's good sensations you
just recognize that and move on
uh and so in this process you sort of
with nothing to do with except sitting
with your own thoughts
you you begin to not put place value
judgments
on the sensory inputs you just observe
them
now we had something my team here at
artemis
we had a uh win agreement where
if the vix was heading up to 30 or above
they were going to interrupt the
meditation retreat
that was not you know it was going to be
so i i had no
external you know my team we run a lot
of systematic trading strategies
so you know my team's able to run things
but without explicit instructions if
there was any financial crisis
they needed to come and interrupt the
meditation retreat and pull me out of it
yeah that's that's prudent planning
damn prudence well day two of that
meditation retreat i'm almost like
please let the vix go above 30.
please
of course you know at that point in time
it did not it was the summer of 2019.
yup um but you've reached this point
where you're
you're thinking yourself okay you know
there's just
you feel good here you feel bad there
all these sensations are fleeting
everything is fleeting
world is entropy it's change so in that
sense the only universal
truth is volatility
change is the only thing that truly
exists everything else is a federal
and you kind of walk out like i can
write that down
and we can talk about it we can talk
about it with respect to markets
it's another thing to really know that
experientially after 10 days of heavy
meditation
that was quite an interesting experience
i would recommend anyone
uh who's brave enough to give it a give
it a try um
and it's true you don't have to go to
bali to go meditate
this this uh this 10-day retreat was
done entirely outside of dallas
you know and it says many good things
but i mean you
in in the days before
the fed bailed out the bond market
you must have looked back on that
experience
and the focus that you had when it felt
like the world was falling apart
when there was for a momentary
point in time a crisis a black swan
so that folk i mean who who knew that
you would be doing
undertaking such a
mind focusing journey
at the precipice of a black swan
yeah it was fascinating because in 2019
right like in many ways it's it's a
mental training for what was
the difficult mental arena of 2020
um and i think it's so vital too
because in this industry it's so easy to
get high
and get low go emotionally high and go
emotionally low
um and to kind of fall in love with
things that
or focus on things that are not really
uh
not really driving uh that not
beneficial to the
investment process when your emotions
and your energy and your seeds so
meditation is a mental discipline that
really helps you stay grounded
particularly during those extreme times
um
so if you want to look at it this way
we tried volatility
and failed we live in a world today that
is largely
devoid of volatility change
is treated as the enemy we we're at the
point where we can't even allow firms
that don't make money to go out of
business
which would be a good change right that
would make room for new entrants
job creators the the good
dynamism in in the economy and in the
markets that is so
vital it's it's lifeblood so i mean i
but and and you know to jump on my
soapbox for just a second
this was a tremendous opportunity for
the federal reserve to
potentially come in guns blazing with
pure quantitative easing but on the
other hand
let the weak companies go
use the coronavirus as an excuse to kind
of
cleanse the system of the weakest links
of the weakest players
so i'm curious what does it say about
we as human investors
that we cannot allow for change
for volatility
yeah i mean i think i think it's we're
fooling ourselves
massively fooling ourselves because
volatility can never be destroyed it can
only be transmuted
in form and shape so if they
keep bailing out markets the way they
have and they refuse to allow the
creative destruction
well you end up with a different form of
destruction
um if they refuse to allow deflation to
occur and for companies to go bankrupt
we're going to end up having that form
of default occur
on the right tail of the return
distribution through stagflation for
inflation and if they continue to try to
plug all the gaps in damn the dam will
fall
through political tournament and which
is i think ultimately
the largest risk the the risk to
democracy
is the ultimate form of so this is the
this is you learn it in a meditation
retreat
chris this is this i mean i hate to
interrupt but what you're saying
is existential is this essential
yeah and i think they i hope they i hope
they realize that i don't think they do
um because i think this this starts to
go beyond just
markets it goes beyond winners and
losers and markets
and it becomes a question of of a social
problem
and i talk about this idea of them being
between a rock and a hard place
where on one end of it let's just we
have this terrible demographics problem
you have the dynamic of slowing growth
uh very strong valuations and they
continually support markets by expansion
of the fed's balance sheet through these
different uh
lending lending lending uh spv
for lending and corporate debt during
the crisis
through repo market support you're
cushioning the deflationary fault
so okay that's great you peg rates to
zero and that will lead to a pension
retirement
default scenario but pension systems
right now
based on their current funding levels
you're looking at 1.7
trillion dollars of u.s state
and local pension deficits and if they
peg rates lower
that's likely to only grow
in fact if we expect returns kind of
where or we've had them you could expect
a dynamic where
that that deficit would grow to three to
nine trillion dollars
so on one end of it they can't let the
system go to the deflationary end
because it will cause a retirement and
pension crisis
um on the flip side of it you can go
ahead and
have massive spending fiscal or you
could make the fed's balance sheet legal
tender
and you end up with this inflationary or
stagflare steering dynamic
which also destroys is another form of
destroying debt
but here's the problem with that as you
know
as you've written about extensively
corporate debt to gdp is at
all time highs and fiscal deficits as a
percentage of gdp
are at the highest levels since world
war ii and only going higher
so in this framework if you just do
basic
roundabout calculations on corporate
balance sheets
if rates rose back to where they were
simply in the late 2000s
if we go back to where rates would be in
2007 you can
just simply buy simply by a back of the
animal
calculation net profits net s p profits
in corporate profits would drop one
third one
one third of the corporate profits and
that's simply
in the the added burden of interest rate
payments
that's given how much debt we currently
have if rates went back to where they
were in the 1970s
all of corporate profits would be taken
up
by higher debt service allocations
and this is an optimistic view because
i'm not
accounting the dynamic where firms white
gold
looked or where they couldn't roll their
debt you have to imagine that if we had
a backup
of interest rates to where they were in
the mid-2000s
many companies many high-yield uh many
many uh poor credit
uh worthy companies wouldn't even be
able to roll their debt and would face
bankruptcy
um so they are truly between a rock and
a hard place but the ultimate rock and
hard place is actually the social
dynamic as well because now we're in a
framework where we had the highest
income disparity
since the great depression right
since prior to great depression so you
know
in trying to thread the needle here by
continuing to funnel money into
uh financial assets which is benefiting
the top one percent of the one percent
uh you you begin to enter into a social
dilemma
um now this deflation inflation problem
is a generational problem
if i'm if i'm 60 years old 70 years old
um i really want them to veer towards
the the the left end of things in the in
the dynamic where
i want them to bail out companies so
that my
my retirement portfolio is maintained
that my wealth grows
but if you're a millennial who doesn't
have a home who doesn't have a stock
portfolio
maybe maybe has a little bit of dogecoin
but you know
you want them to spend as much money as
possible
and inflate their way out of this crisis
because you don't you don't have to
worry about your retirement portfolio
you don't have much in savings you don't
have to worry about that
um imploding in fact you have tons of
debt
so the inflation would get rid of that
again so
part of the political turmoil we
actually are seeing is actually somewhat
of a demographic
conflict as well between who's going to
win
financially depending on which
which way they view and this is a very
combustible scenario um and in this
combustible scenario we see markets
continue to trench higher and
speculative mania continue to rage in an
extreme way
so it there is a difference
societally speaking if you will
between prior fed bailouts and where we
are today and when you're talking about
the top one percent
it's it's notable if you will that a few
that a few very famous hedge fund
managers have come out
publicly and said i'm fabulously wealthy
i travel in a private jet i've got homes
all over the world
and i'm part of the problem right now
and we're going to have to close
this divide and hats off
i mean they made their money
legitimately but
it's something to see when you've got
people in palm beach
recognizing how big this problem
is becoming and it looks
like rather than address the root
problem right which is and
children in america don't have the same
access to the same level of education
that's kind of at the root if you will
of income inequality
instead of addressing that the
government looks
to be trying to paper it over
with stimulus with unemployment benefits
um what does it
say that fiscal policy is
able to be as aggressive as it is today
what does that say about the federal
reserve's role
in where we've become as a society
i know that's a deep question but you're
you're the man
yeah i think it's you know uh i was as
you know i was recently at home
talking to my parents both my parents i
grew up the son of two doctors but my
parents were very
uh very lower i would say lower class
growing up my mom's my mom's uh
dad and my grandfather literally
delivered fruit
um it was essentially a drove trucks to
deliver fruit to grocery stores
um so i was talking to my my mom about
it
and uh they they were dirt poor growing
up but um
i looked at what he made and we made the
conversion adjustment
for what my grandfather made as a fruit
truck driver
back in the 50s and we converted that
based on inflation to what what it would
be today
so as as a fruit truck driver he made
close to 60 000
a year in today's money back in the back
in the 50s
that's kind of median income yeah that
was medium that's
truly truly median income now um
so if you look at that that was enough
to have a very
meager meager life but he was able to
you know provide um and my grandmother
didn't need to work after a certain
point
well that same job today probably pays
about 25 000
a year you cannot survive on that job
there's that's not a single income
there's no way you can you can barely
make even
you know on a 60 000 you know income
today
to that effect so what we have seen as a
situation there's been this great
goal that's been pulled over people's
eyes and i'm not making a political
argument here i'm just stating realities
you know in the 1970s you had a
situation where
uh that nixon shock and they d pegged
uh the dollar versus gold and uh
since that point in time real adjusted
wages
have not risen they've been static since
the late 60s early 70s
um and a big part of that as well
has been we've also been exporting our
inflation via globalization
and there was a major factor that
changed markets at that point in time
the 1970s i always talk about this idea
of
uh autocorrelation or serial correlation
markets used to trend
that's what i mean by auto correlation
prior to the 70s um beginning in the
1970s there was this
seismic shift in the way markets behaved
um and all of a sudden we ended up with
this framework where there was heavy
mean reversion
that began to exhibit itself and part of
that is that you have this huge
run-up at interest rates and then what
what that's what they've been able to do
is every single time that there's been
some any type of crisis they're
available rates
to cushion with the asset prices so you
have this
massive gain in um massive gain
in financial assets from 1980
participating
um that is truly almost unequaled in the
history of human civilization and we've
covered we've covered this yeah uh
there's an interview with you and i
talked
at length about this um that's now on
youtube it's a real vision for you and
talk about building 100 portfolio
but effectively 91 of the gains in 60 40
stock portfolio
um occurred between 1982
and 2007. 91 percent of the games over
the last 100 years was this incredible
period where you had huge gains
both stocks and bonds lower
deregulation lowering of taxes
and all these things really benefited
people
who were saving benefited the wealthy
benefited people who had financial
assets
but it came at the expense of
it came at the expense of increases in
readjusted earnings um and i i don't
think people understand necessarily
what's going on
with the fed or what's going on with
fiscal policy but they intrinsically
understand something
is wrong because they're working harder
and
we're talking about the average person
you know this is the average person in
west virginia or the average person in
cleveland ohio
who is working working as hard as people
work 60 years ago but can't seem to get
ahead
and there's an anger and that anchor is
causing polarization on both ends of
this political spectrum
is being funneled to both right-wing and
left-wing
ideologies that are using that angle
um and that that that is creating this
dangerous
dangerous dangerous conundrum in a big
way
um and it really represents a
secular shift we are seeing there was a
a secular regime
that started after they devalued
um devalued fiat versus gold
and we are now nearing the end of that
secular regime
and what's occurring is that they are
using more debt more balance sheet
uh more fed balance g simply to paper
over this central problem rather than
addressing it at which point the central
problem
has become so large that it's almost
impossible to embrace
the volatility now
part of we go back to the meditation
retreat what one needs to do is accept
the volatility
you sit there and you recognize your
foot is in pain and asleep
you recognize it you understand it you
embrace it
right um what they're doing is the
opposite
they're doing everything they possibly
can to
cover up that volatility and
what they're doing is in essence
creating a super decline
that is either going to come from a
market standpoint or from a political
social standpoint and uh
and i think they're stuck
chris i think you're right um
and it's interesting that again that we
have
segwayed from monetary policy being able
able to
paper things over to needing the
combination
of monetary and fiscal which
is being embraced
there is a lot i mean the hostilities on
my twitter feed whenever you
bring up the idea of wages or
unemployment benefits
there's this there's this anger element
that's out there
that you know corporate america has
stuck it to us wall street has stuck it
to us for so look look at them in their
mansions and
they flaunt their wealth and it's it's
our turn
it's our turn to get paid it's not our
turn to work
but it's our turn to get paid and
i'm not again this isn't a this is an
observation
as you said it's not a political
statement i'm just i see it it's
visceral
and it makes you wonder
which is going to be the more
capitalistic
country in the end the united states
or china
it's you know this ties into something
with some of the speculation
and we talk about this idea of
um crypto and all of these other meme
stocks and these
these well and you you look at uh
dogecoin which you know now has exploded
more than the yes like its gains this
year
is more than what you would have holding
the s p for
over a decade um but effectively an
asset that has no value and
we can look and look at other periods of
speculative meaning
right the dot com bubble the nifty 50
bubble
um we go all the way back to the south
sea bubble to a mania
but there was something there's
something very dark
about where this speculation is going
and that ties into that political disc
discontent
and it ties into uh the future of
capitalism
in a very dark and negative way in the
past as misguided as
all of these other bubbles were they
were based
on a true enthusiastic
embrace of new technology or
opportunities
misguided but truly unembracing it
tangible all the way back to the south
sorry sorry um i was just saying there
was something tangible backing the
speculation
there was something there there was an
at least a narrative
right you go to the south sea ball right
it was it was all about the new colonies
these new colonies are going to change
the world you know we go to the mid
mid 1800s the rare world and there was a
huge bubble there like oh my goodness
the railroads are going to change the
world we go into the the great
depression and
and you look at radio and automobile was
going to change the world these things
did but they were overvalued that's the
stocks associated with them
the dot-com bubble the internet i always
talk about this i tweeted about it how
mary meeker
you know you go back and i read the old
barons interviews mary maker she was 100
correct she was right about everything
about the transformative power of the
internet but she
the thing she got wrong with evaluations
so
as misguided as all of these other
speculative manias were
they are based on narratives about hope
for the future
but this mania has taken a very
negative turn because you look at
something like dogecoin
it's a joke it literally was a joke
it was invented as a mean joke
so what's happening now is in the past
people were buying
and speculating based on narratives and
hope
today the speculation
is not in search of value it's actually
being done
to mock value people
are actually saying this entire game
game is rigged
let's all get together and bid up
some meme stock or meme crypto that
ultimately we all know it has no value
but because of this convoluted world
we're in
we are going to in mass
create value and create speculation
this is a form it's not capitalism
it's not socialism it's financial
nihilism and
this is scary this is
truly the most scary thing where people
are saying
the nihilism is saying the entire thing
is rigged let's just
we know it's rigged let's go ahead and
funnel our energy into means that we
know
are mocking that um if i'm
a policy maker that should be theory
that's to truly be scary and it's being
driven by
the younger generation oh yeah now
we embody the values that
we embody the like the world embodies
the values of the people that have
power so
to the effect that
nothing like capitalism in its purest
form
should incentivize value creation
you know jeff bezos said this you know
find a way to add value
and what capitalism should do over the
long run
is it should incentivize those people
and those firms that are adding value
and what they have done is because
they've divorced
the they've divorced
and controlled the price of risk they've
divorced
markets from having any true volatility
and they created a massive moral hazard
they've created a dynamic where people
intentionally
mocking the system are chasing assets
they know
have no value
the reason that they're chasing them is
to mock
the very idea of value
and for that reason one has to look and
say this system
is breaking it's breaking
in ways that are hard to discern it's
it's breaking not in a sense of like i'm
not talking about markets declining in
or inflation exploding we're talking
about
the value set of people
and how they embrace and look at
capitalism
as a tool for good is falling apart
and i think that's it's on it's
on one end of it you have the cynical
aspect
where the people who are young
capitalists are saying
forget it i'm going to go put my money
in dogecoin or i'm going to put my money
in
in whatever meme stock and i'm going to
write it because it's all meaningless
or the opposite end of that are the
people
truly like the communist party which you
know you you look at people with
socialist or communist views actually
truly communist views
in america has been there's been a huge
increase in the number of millennials
and gen z that are interested
in those extreme and failed ideas of
communism
and so this is what people have to be
watching out for
this is what policymakers should be
actually looking at and worrying about
um at night uh because we've broken the
value system
of capitalism itself
so you know um it's interesting
chris because when you frame
dogecoin as you have when you
bring the idea of decentralized finance
into the framework um
you have to stop and wonder
what is it what is it
that regulators are so fearful of
that they won't even they won't even
hint that they're exploring what's going
on
in these in the crypto space in the d
fight they won't even hint
at it what are they so afraid of as
regulators
they they seem to be the regulations in
this country seem to be
uh i i scratch my head on because
you can run a responsible hedge fund
that has a solid track record
and somehow you're you're not
appropriate and not an appropriate
investment for
people who are an average person on the
street you have to be an accredited
sophisticated investment
yet they'll let an 18 year old
invest in
lever up their lever up portfolio with
options or invest in obscure crypto
tokens or invest in a double lever
fixed etp
it's so there's not a lot that makes
sense
no in that um at all uh
and when you look at the when you look
at the regulation the crypto space
and um no it's hard for me to jump
i'm not a crypto expert but just kind of
looking at it tangentially
um i i understand that there's
incredible opportunity in that space an
incredible opportunity for blockchain
technology
there's also a lot of legitimate
criticisms about how it might be used
by enemies of the american state how
defy
um and how uh offshore leverage
like in many ways i i look at what's
occurring offshore in some of these
crypto exchanges
and what's occurring in the d5 space it
resembles a lot of what
occurred with stocks prior to the 1930s
where there were bucket shops and
investment trusts that were
enabling a tremendous amount of uh
of leverage unregulated leverage and
speculation and we're seeing that you
know
you can't do it on coinbase but you take
your money on a coinbase you put it in
in an offshore exchange and all of a
sudden uh you're able to
deliver that about 10 or 20 times um
and it's it's backed by some sort of a
uh uh
uh stable coin um and you're able to
loan out your i mean it's it's
very very similar to bucket shops i mean
nothing you know history doesn't repeat
but it rhymes
sure um so it does feel like they're
behind the curve in that
in that sense um and it is quite
puzzling
i you know i was talking about this
uh with my green um on a different
interview but you know i just i had a
strange theory
that maybe maybe that crypto is a
volatility
um uh absorption
method right now where like you can have
these crazy crypto
tokens that that in effect that's a
sponge up the excess speculation that
otherwise would be going into things
like u.s home prices
and that they'll regulate crypto as a
form of a shadow form of monetary
tightening
when it's to their benefit but maybe i'm
just giving them too much credit
i don't know well i mean i you know i
look and and
i know i'm not inside of regulators
heads either i can't explain
either what what's happening here but
you can draw a line between
what would happen if crypto fell out of
bed and what the
follow-on effect would be for other
overvalued assets
and that's the only thing i can come up
with is is is that that i mean that
would be a tremendous source of fear
on the part not of regulators but
regulators
bosses they're they're superiors
aka politicians jay powell
people like that yeah
it's it has created a dynamic
um this is something it's a theme i've
talked about before but this
flows over fundamentals and
i think this has gained a lot of
traction over the last couple years
you know i wrote a paper about it back
in 2018 but it's only been amplified to
that effect
um but there's this there's this battle
for the soul of capitalism
which is do you evaluate an investment
based on
intrinsic net worth which seems so
old-fashioned now
or do you evaluate an investment based
on the momentum in the flows
and this kind of comes into the passive
versus active argument
so you know in the past the warren
buffett methodology the charlie munger
methodology is like well let's look at
the intrinsic values of this asset
and see what is going to give off cash
flows good business does that remote
now it's just like well we're going to
do factor analysis or we're going to
simply put everything into
it ultimately doesn't matter all that
matters is that more money is flowing in
and there's an expectation that somebody
is going to continually provide that
money
uh namely namely that if markets ever
get out of control
that the the fed will
backstop the system and provide for a
backstop and moral hazard of losses
so naturally that's just gravitated and
saying well it's actually
the flows that create value not
intrinsic value
and now that's divorced itself now the
flow is it used to be like we're going
to do factor analysis and all this other
stuff and
we're going to discern all this right
now it doesn't even matter the only
thing that matters is
what you can drive flows by tweeting
about something and that's what's
new um so the soul of capitalism is
under fire
of course you know as as mike green has
done excellent work on
you know this active was passive dynamic
and i i actually replicated his work in
the early days on that
where you know if you have only uh if
you have a market that's driven entirely
by flows
you can have huge surges up and huge
surges down
the entire market is driven by each
incremental buyer or each incremental
seller
and that presents a lot of problems um
so
it's you end up with these huge tails of
the return distribution which is what
what we're seeing actually but the tails
occur on both the upside and the
downside
where um where markets hit a liquidity
gap
there's no liquidity even in things like
treasuries and we're having huge
sell-off like in march
and each incremental seller is causing
big gaps down
so we had the fastest decline in history
in march
and then you have the federal reserve in
global central banks
and also fiscally you know policymakers
on a fiscal basis
backstop that whole financial system and
it gaps back up
um this is this is not an
emblematic of a healthy environment um
we saw that type of behavior back in the
30s we did that's the last time we saw
yeah just saw that behavior we took out
the 1930s
yeah we took out the i think 2020 check
out the
record fast decline in the stock market
yep and people people really fail to
remember that in 32 and 34
there were 80 percent gains that occur
over a period of
a few months after so
that this is what happens when you have
a flow-driven market where just
everything gaps up
and down based on based on based on each
incremental wire or sell-off
um so it's it creates a moral
moral dilemma um you know one of the
things we've talked a lot about
is that all hope is not lost um
you know at artemis we have a we have a
phrase where we talk about
this idea that you know don't be afraid
don't predict it prepare
and by implementing a portfolio
that has diversification by market
regimes
you can protect yourself against left
and right tail events
regardless of what what occurs
and i think that's the way to look at it
right now that
if you're constructing a portfolio if
you're constructing a portfolio it's
incredibly important
to have the core asset classes of bonds
and stocks
but to also have assets that can perform
on those tails the tails that
that that do well in the event that
there is a massive deflation or
tails of stagflation and inflation so
things like you know augmenting a
portfolio with
diversifiers like long volatility and
ctas
or diversifiers like gold and actually
holding those things
together in a composite portfolio is the
key
to being able to to actually create
wealth through these periods of secular
change
without needing to predict outcomes
because right now it's almost impossible
to predict outcomes
in a world where everything is driven by
flows
and value doesn't matter in the short
term at least
um and it's it's driven by policy makers
and their choices and the reflexivity
between policy makers and market
participants
um you can't predict what's going to
happen all you can do
is you can you can hold and diversify
your portfolio
based not by asset but based on market
regime dynamics
and that's how you survive this that's
how you
thrive through this and
that's i think that's the lesson that
history has taught us
to that effect i think it's the lesson a
lot of people including pensions are
going to learn the hard way
if if the classic 60 40 portfolios
that most people have or not are are not
uh
remedied or revised so
um i i would be remiss to not
recognize where you are today which is
the home price appreciation capital of
the country
home prices are up 30 year over year in
austin texas period end
um and you know i got the sensation
with the discussion we just had that we
could have been having the same
discussion
real estate and you know when you
mention
pensions the reason that they've piled
into real estate
private equity funds in recent years
is they're looking for a diversification
vehicle
they're looking for a hard asset in the
event that inflation takes off
it seems like americans are doing the
same thing
and they're paying up wildly for housing
and it's i mean i i
it's not a matter of subprime lending
but there is definitely the same element
of speculative
fervor mania going on in housing right
now
and i know you've got slightly different
views about
about how much real estate and or if
you're an individual housing
can protect you in a downturn
yeah it's interesting with austin um you
know as you know
uh and both of us are texas i'm i'm a
transplant from
from uh new york and california to texas
but i moved
uh six seven years ago um and i moved
artemis
from california to austin strategically
when i wanted to begin growing the firm
and hiring people
and i loved california i loved living in
l.a
and a beautiful apartment on the beach
it was a lot of fun to live out there
but when i looked at growing a business
what i
saw was what i saw was a state
that had uh tremendous pension
obligations
and where the only lever to pull was
taxing businesses
and i looked at the trajectory out a
decade and i said to myself this is not
a sustainable mix
because you're in a you enter into a
doom loop um
where you have a framework where uh
you have to to pay off liabilities you
have to
continuously tax productive businesses
and that works in a big market up cycle
but the minute you have a down cycle
um you're going to lose money you're
gonna your
liabilities are gonna increase you're
gonna have to increase the taxes on the
main companies
and this is going to create a mass
exodus problem
um so i was like boy this is this is a
big issue it's the biggest
issue as a business owner i so i moved
artemis out
to austin strategically in in the end of
2013 2014
i've been shocked at how um accurate
that viewpoint has been
um and i uh and austin has been
transforming
and one of the things we looked at was
we looked at the the ratio of
prices to uh high cost the
home prices in high cost states with
high tax obligations
these are places like uh los angeles san
francisco
new york new jersey we looked at that
ratio
to home prices in uh better tax
uh jurisdictions and uh and and
the uh the growth uh more affordable
cities like nashville
austin miami um
the ratio peaked at over three times the
median house price
in around 2013 2014 and gradually we've
been
seeing a normalization of that process
where
uh where gradually the prices and austin
are coming up in the prices
in the high cost or the prices and the
low cost jurisdictions are
increasing the prices in the high cost
jurisdictions have flattened or
are down it is a lifestyle arbitrage
i think and it's one of the ways that i
think some
some companies corporations and
individuals have been
seeking to kind of get around that
the problem of the doom loop but the
doom loop exists
as a country in addition to individual
states
um and i guess i got a little
target talking about this no no this is
fascinating i mean this is
no no you're not off target at all at
all yeah but it's
i i think the the transformation in
places like austin have been
it's been incredible i mean i the city
is almost not
not that it's radically different than
when when i first moved here and
continues to change
every every year um but of course i
think there's going to be that lifestyle
arbitrage it is an art it's an art
arbitrage and it will probably
exist like any arbitrage for maybe
another decade or two decades
before it evens out um
but it does it does it does uh
now what's scary though what's truly
scary is that
that arbitrage is occurring between
states
as a country we need to make sure it
doesn't occur
between countries
and this is the danger
this is the danger in a post-capitalist
reality that um
you know do does it become beneficial
for people to
to to domicile their capital elsewhere
you know in a framework and that's
that's truly
an endgame issue if we look at a bigger
picture
um uh in the movement of global capital
and the way that this kind of endgame of
the problems that we're in could could
could occur over the next 20 years
yep uh that that means uh you you
actually just
finished answering my china question
try it into the china thing right now
i'm afraid it does
because that is where the growth is it
really is
up and coming in east asia um so
let's let's talk turkey for a minute um
have valuations lost all
meaning in in december 1920
the case schiller the cape
price earnings ratio was 4.8
today we're almost at 38. so
almost eight times where we were when
stocks were the cheapest in the history
of u.s
of the us stock market and and that is
but 38 is still not 44 which which it
was in december 2000 so we're not quite
there
but so price to earnings is the gentlest
of all
valuation metrics if you're talking
about the warren buffett indicator
market capitalization to gdp
price to sales if you look at margin
debt
but are all of these metrics
meaningless chris
well it's funny because you get on
twitter and uh
i think unfortunately i'm on twitter
unfortunately uh but people uh
the younger generations are ridiculed
laughing
at evaluations just today i was looking
at it and you know they they're laughing
ridiculing the case-shiller indices as
being completely meaningless
but it's like we've seen this before
value is meaningless until it's
until it's everything um so
uh it's definitely meaningless in the
short term
you know it's definitely meaningless in
the short term and it's
and the i think the problem though is
that
is that the fed has been front running
value investors for so long
i mean values had one of the longest
periods of underperformance
in the data set in history and one of
the reasons by that i i think
warren buffett summed it up you know we
said well we couldn't
the minute we thought about looking at
something to buy in march
and paraphrasing you know what he wrote
you know all of a sudden it was it was
over with and there's nothing was
attractive
so to to that to that point
um the fed has been front running value
investors
they're never letting anything get down
to intrinsic value they're providing
liquidity
to prop things up um and as a result
what that does
is it puts out puts out of business
responsible actors
so a system
comes to embody a system comes to embody
the values of its winners it's the point
of capitalism
you add value you win
you get money well
the longer they divorce the process
of value uh seeking
an intrinsic value of seeking they've
divorced that from reality
to the point where people who do seek
value
are ridiculed and are penalized
and as a result of that they and i've
seen this go out of business
seeing some very solid investors
who invest in solid principles go out of
business
because they're seeking value well
the net effect of that is that that
money then
that used to go to responsible actors is
now funneled into flow followers
meme followers and it embraces
or worse yet those who we make wealthy
those
who are looking to destroy the system
through
through things like crypto right crypto
is an anti-system asset
and you are rewarding those individuals
those individuals become powerful and
their value system
comes to dominate our world
that's a financial realistic reality
and every day we edge closer to a
post-capitalist world
because of what they are doing mm-hmm
and who they are
rewarded and the volatility
uh the volatility uh
uh suppression that they
that they embrace you know the
the aspect the secret to meditation
we go back to that concept again it's
you don't ignore the pain you don't
ignore the blips
you recognize it and you recognize
it for being a female you don't
ignore it you don't paper over it this
the first step to actually being able to
meditate
for 10 hours a day is simply to be like
my
foot hurts yeah it does i recognize that
i recognize that as being valid and i'm
going to move on to the next sensation
um
if you end up continuously
papering over your sensations especially
the bad ones
and that's what a drug addict is and
that's what we are
that's what that's what capitalism is
today
it's essentially a drug act but the drug
is
is stimulus in all its forms
so chris there is um
when you're not meditating and we'll
we'll kind of wrap things up here
when you're not meditating and you are
actively thinking
uh you've been thinking about a new
mouse trap
i've heard um can you just give a
thumbnail uh sharp ratio for dummies
definition and explain
why why it's not as relevant as people
perceive it as being
and if there is potentially something
better out there
well you and i uh almost a year ago we
we sat down for an interview in our
offices here back when we do that
and um we talked about this idea of a
hundred year portfolio
um this was a blunt a brute force
attempt i back tested every financial
engineering strategy
popular portfolio allocation strategy
and i looked at
how do they perform over 100 years and
what we found was this idea of what we
call the dragon portfolio
is this concept that you diversify your
investments
based on secular regimes or your
diversified
investments based on market regime
rather than asset class and that
portfolio of five asset classes which
was
um stocks bonds long volatility
commodity trend and trend and momentum
and
fiat alternatives like gold that
portfolio
outperformed almost every portfolio from
6040 risk parity everything
um you have one fifth allocation of each
of those five classes which perform in
different market regimes
now we did that interview before 2000
before the big crisis in 2020 the dragon
portfolio did fantastic in 2020.
you truly ended up having a situation
where every quarter
was a was a game because uh uh because
the different components of the
portfolio were together
so i found that really interesting i
looking at portfolio construction it led
me down a different path
and i realized how poor sharp ratio is
now a sharp ratio is the dominic
metric that is used in the investment
industry
you go into a pitch meeting with an
investor and they're like what is your
sharper issue
that's the number one question and
the what's interesting about that
question
is it's irrelevance first of all
william sharp when he was 32 years old
when he kind of came up with a sharp
ratio
um which was published over the 1960s
um he himself indicated that it was
intended to be used for an aggregate
portfolio it's not intended to be used
for individual
components of that portfolio you use it
to evaluate portfolios against other
portfolios
well the real question that people are
they want to know is
when they're allocating money can
will that investment improve my
portfolio
that's the real real question that
people want to know
and sharper ratio gives you no
information
in fact i will sit back and say that
sharp ratios actually lead you down the
wrong path
they're not additive they're not
adequate
if you put take a bunch of positive
sharp ratio investments
put them on top of one another your
total portfolio can actually be more
risky
your risk adjuster returns can actually
go down
and this is because sharp ratios do not
measure two things they don't measure
uh correlations and they don't measure
the tails of the return distribution
but if you're looking at diversification
those are the two things that
really matter you know we talk about are
we going to deflation are we gonna go
into stagflation
those are tails those are tails
so i looked back and i said to myself
this is a problem
how can we correct this the problem has
existed in other fields
sports is a field where this has existed
you know in moneyball paul d podesta um
uh who was uh kind of a general manager
with billy beam
and the oakland a's and he once said and
i'm paraphrasing this
uh you don't buy players
you buy wins and to buy wins
you need to buy runs
now what he meant is that in baseball
they evaluated players based on the
statistics
like rbis and steals that were largely
irrelevant
and what they should have been
evaluating players on were things like
their
percentage on their on base percentages
which actually drove
wins and the oakland a's were able to
use that for strategic advantage well if
i sit back and say this
you are not if you're an allocator or
you're a retiree you are not
buying an investment or a hedge fund
you are trying to buy a better portfolio
and to buy a better portfolio
you need to buy non-correlation
and left and right tails
what you care about is not
the investment itself what you care
about is what that investment
does to help your portfolio win and
sharp ratios tell you nothing
to this effect absolutely nothing
so when when i'm looking at this we all
know
that in sports you can have players that
have
gaudy individual statistics they might
score a lot they might do all these
things
but when you put that player on your
team your team
loses because even though that player
might score
and have all these irrelevant stats that
look good on paper they have
deficiencies in their game
maybe they're not good defenders maybe
they're a ball hawk
these things that actually result in the
team losing
so sports develop these things like
metrics like
uh plus minus ratios or another metric
is wins over replacement player
it's saying if i add this player to my
team
do i get more wins or do i get more
losses
well we are going to be introducing this
concept
that we call seaward which is a little a
little arrogant so i named it
put put my own name in there it's the
coal wins over replacement portfolio
and we're going to release a paper
that's coming on out
that will detail how to calculate c warp
the benefits of c work and and
uh we'll include code in that so people
can implement this
what c14 does is we assume you have a
starting portfolio
like a 60 40 stock bond portfolio that's
your starting portfolio
what you do is you assume that you're
going to borrow money
at prevailing interest rates and layer
on
a new investment on top of that
portfolio
and about a 25 does that
help your risk adjusted returns
a positive coal winds above replacement
portfolio
means that the asset is helping your
pushing your portfolio out on the
efficient frontier giving you more
return for your nervous risk
a negative c warp says it's doing the
opposite
um pretty simplistic conceptually but
it's amazing that it hasn't been
implemented yet
we ran this on 30 different diversifiers
and hedge fund indices
and we assumed the base level we sue two
base level portfolios one is
is um the s p 500 and the other one is a
60 40 portfolio
just standard portfolios it turns out
using the s p as a baseline only about
one
third of hedge fund strategies surveyed
ended up
benefiting the end portfolio
only one third and it's incredible
to see so many hedge funds
that have good sharp ratios actually
have
negative wins above replacement
portfolio
and the reason being is because
those hedge funds or those diversifiers
are
replicating the same correlations
and negative exposure to tails that are
already
in a 60 40 portfolio
so what effectively what those
hedge funds are doing is that
they're leveraging a form of beta
or they have negative exposure to tails
either
left tail or right tail either deflation
or stagflation
you don't need to have that same profile
layered on top of your skin portfolio it
doesn't help your portfolio
that's like a player that that is a ball
hawk
that has nice statistics they have a
nice sharp ratio but they don't help
your team win
other assets that have
lower sharp ratios actually have very
high
winds above replacement portfolio
metrics
and what that's saying is that even
though these assets maybe don't look as
good on
people they have huge value
for pushing your portfolio out on the
efficient frontier
huge value and those assets
is incredible the number one ranked
asset
is the cboe eureka hedge long volatility
hedge fund index
the collection of long ball hedge funds
had the most
benefit um gold had
huge benefit as well treasuries of
course do
um and this is layering on top of the s
p merger arbitrage
was a surprise one for me merger
arbitrage strategies did very well
um along with uh relative value
volatility
and um along with uh
the other the other index was um ctas
systematic ctas so it's very interesting
that if we look at the go back to the
dragon portfolio
um i didn't really know how these
metrics would turn out
we have two ways of getting to the same
conclusion
the dragon portfolio and the paper that
i released last year
went into detail like rigorous detail
going back and recreating these return
histories going back 100 years so that's
like the brute force method
right and based on that we came up with
hey you know portfolio of stocks bonds
gold
volatility and trend following
commodities is an amazing portfolio
if we use wins above replacement
portfolio
which is an analytical method of
mathematical
derivation more elegant not brute force
you come to nearly the same conclusion
actually the exact same conclusion
maybe you want to add in a little merger
arbitrage in there just to
spice it up um so
i think this is going to be eye-opening
for people um
it really sits back and you know you
look at institutions
who are you know they might be jumping
into things
like private equity that's a huge area
of interest
like let's let's jump into understand
private equity has very good sharp
ratios
but if you look at seawarp hmm
not so great why is that
well private equity does well in two
environments
well it does well in one environment
where you have stable
and lower interest rates and rising
secular growth
in the event of a deflationary collapse
private equity is negatively exposed to
the left tail of the return distribution
in the event of a stagnationary crisis
private equity is going to be heard by
the increasing interest rates
so it has these elements of like kind of
a short straddle
on top of it you have poor liquidity
private equity takes money away where
long voltage in a crisis where long
volatility gives you money on prices
this is something that a sharp ratio
doesn't measure but a c warp does a much
better job measurably
so sure enough what what something like
wins above replacement portfolio is
saying is that well even though
something like an average private equity
fund of course if you're talking the
best private equity funds you know maybe
the best of anything can add value but
if you ask the average or medium private
equity fund
is just simply replicating exposure you
already have in your portfolio
layering on more of that exposure more
of the negative tail exposure
more of the same correlated exposure is
not
benefiting your end portfolio and
sharp ratios do not tell you that but
the sea war wins above replacement
portfolio will tell you that
um so i'm very very excited to to to
bring
out this this paper um i
really think we also show that if
you can layer if you choose multiple c
warp investments and layer them on top
of one another
you will get a better portfolio you will
get a better return for you
so we walk the walk we show people how
to do this
whereas if you layer multiple sharp high
sharp ratio investments on one another
your portfolio can actually suffer on a
risk adjusted basis
let me give another example on this here
i love this example
uh xiv do you remember this this etf
the one that blew up in 2018 oh yeah
so xiv was a short volatility etf um
and uh you know the time like i think in
2017 mike green and i
you know we were doing a keynote we
actually had an argument with the
the the cio of that firm
saying hey i think your product's not
going to survive
um got a lot of sure enough we were
right
um maybe unfortunately because a lot of
people were burned by that
but what happened with xiv is that it
was taking tremendous tail risk
and it had these incredible returns but
then
on february 5th 2018 it completely blew
up and lost
99 of its time well let's just
assume you knew nothing about xid you
knew nothing about the investment all
you had were these veterans
as of january 2018 one month before
accidentally blew up
you looked at and said wow this thing
has a sharp ratio of 1.78
it's incredible sharp ratio and in fact
if i add xiv to my portfolio
my portfolio short ratio goes up
like wow this is great let's put this
xib
thing in to our portfolio but
if you had looked at sea water
the sea work of xib it had a very
negative sea mark
at a very negative winds above
replacement portfolio
um and what c-mark was telling you is
like okay even though this thing had a
very good stroke ratio
it was heavily correlated with the s p
and
its tails were more negatively exposed
to drawdowns
in the s p so by layering it on top of
your portfolio
you were amplifying your risk in fact
you were better off
just leveraging the s p 500 itself
rather than adding x id to your
portfolio
um so you could have come to that
determination
without knowing anything about the
product and simply
looking at sea wall versus alternative
sequence
um so i think there's a huge power to
this i think
investments like long volatility like
trend following
and apparently merger arbitrage that's
something i learned from this process
um are incredibly undervalued
comparative
to many of these other risk premium
allocations
that are much more popular among
institutions um
and i really look forward to um i know
you got an advanced copy of that paper
but i'm really looking forward to
releasing that publicly
and we're going to provide code and
information so people can
use this new analytical tool to their
benefit
and we can we can put sharp ratio to
rest
um as an outdated uh well-meaning but
outdated and ultimately irrelevant
well chris um we're gonna wrap it up
there by the way i'm totally
spooked because february the 5th 2018
was also jay pal's first day in office
that's right i mean when you said it i
just went whoa
i mean just it's i don't know spooky um
but one last one last question this is
going to be pretty easy
so los angeles new york
what's your all this talk about
moneyball what's what's your baseball
team
well i'm more of a basketball guy so um
i'm much more of a basketball guy so uh
as far as baseball i mean i guess i'm
gonna have to go with the tigers because
i'm pretty
you know pretty pretty uh agnostic on
baseball and that's you know kind of
more
close to my hometown but i i grew up
playing basketball despite my
five foot ten stature and uh i've always
been a pistons fan
there you go and part of my part of his
ideas on sea warp
and this other stuff has come because i
grew up watching dennis rodman
i watched i i always kind of think of
um long ball and what we do is as a
as a as a proxy for uh dennis robins
kind of a proxy for that because
okay robbing the tax twos and the
outlandish behavior
but robin was such a good rebounder that
this is a perfect example
that he averaged 18 rebounds a game six
standard deviations better than the
median rebounder
he would give your team second and third
chance opportunities to score
and so rodman even though he had really
mediocre statistics as a scorer and
every
everything else he was such a good
rebounder that
when you put rodman on the team
the wins above replacement went through
the roof his wins above replacement were
among the top 20 in nba history
because you give michael jordan a second
and third chance
to score michael jordan is probably
going to make good on that
so rodman's a classic example
of where a guy who doesn't look that
impressive
by the traditional statistics is able to
when paired with other players who could
score
result in team wins and
so i think maybe a lot of my my love of
this
anti-correlation and my love of this
kind of comes from
watching guys like dennis rodman
and guys like ben wallace uh and
more recently draymond green and how
they can impact
the game in ways that are not tangible
general managers have figured that out
yep but
apparently we're still struggling with
that in the investment space
unfortunately
uh i tell you what i'll reach out to
dennis rodman and make sure that he gets
this uh this interview
i'm sure he'd be tickled pink to hear
that he's got a higher sea work ratio
so um in any event chris i would love to
do i i would be up for that any day
i bet you would i i don't know how that
would go
well we'll find him on twitter we'll
find him he's findable
no worries um listen this was
on dennis rodman and investing and talk
to him about that i would i'd be up for
it any day oh that would be fun
that would be a blast all right well
we'll leave it on that and i'll i'll add
that to my to-do list
and seriously i appreciate you taking
all this time this was
great this is fabulous this was fun i
learned a lot um
and i'll look forward to talking to you
the next time
thank you thank you so much take care
wow i mean wow that was
amazing i'm so delighted that we got
that much time
with chris cole he really has come up
with a new mouse trap
he's going to unleash this new way to
add
value to your portfolio to your
investments to the world
so that we can all use it i mean this is
it's like saying pfizer is going to
release its
you know the secret sauce to its its
vaccination on day one
so i hope that you enjoyed that as much
as i did
you might want to watch it a few times i
know i'll go back and watch it
if you want to know more of the
backstory on mike green
which he mentioned several times in the
interview the good news is
we've already sat down with mike green
so you can get the full story if you go
back
and listen to that episode of down the
middle
and if you haven't yet don't forget
please subscribe thanks much this is
daniel
demartino booth and i'll see you next
[Music]
time